-Also, we are so excited
on this holiday week,
the final shows of 2023,
to have our dear friend
and bandleader Fred Armisen
back with us on drums.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks.
-Fred, once again,
no one has accomplished more
in 2023 than you.
You're always working. We're
happy when we have you here.
We also know that you're out
on the road doing stand up,
doing other projects,
and I'm always just blown away
when I hear the things
you're working on.
-Aww, thank you.
-And I have to ask you,
is this true
that you are releasing this week
your own Christmas album?
-I am.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Yeah.
It's a celebration
of the Mummy.
You know, like...
-The -- The horror movie
character of the Mummy?
-Yeah. Well, people think of it
as a horror movie character,
but it's just a character
for all seasons.
So I'm just trying
to do something
so, like, to include the Mummy
in more Christmassy,
you know, things.
And it's just like, you know --
-When you say, like, "more,"
like, I would say,
like, start --
we're starting at zero, right?
[ Laughter ]
Like, I feel like there are
zero holiday classics
that include
the Mummy right now.
-You're right about that...
-Yeah.
-...actually.
And this is just a way
to bring that back.
Because Christmas --
-But, again, you say "back"...
[ Laughter ]
Was there a time when there were
a lot of Mummy Christmas songs?
-Just the old traditions,
you know what I mean?
Like the old -- Like,
let's bring that back,
like the 1800s
and, you know, like...
-So in the 1800s, there were
a lot of Christmas songs
that had the Mummy in them?
-I gather.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you do any research?
-Some. I --
You know,
the way I do research
is I've got a bunch of friends.
They are awesome.
I think they're here.
You guys are great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are here.
-So it sounds -- It sounds like
maybe the whole audience.
-Yeah.
-It's most of them,
and they're the best.
They're like --
But they're the best.
They're -- They work so hard.
They're just so cool.
They're down to earth,
they're sweet.
And they --
-I know you've been really
keeping it under wraps, but...
And you don't have to have
any music for it.
Just, you know, a cappella,
could you just real quick
sing us one of your Mummy
Christmas songs?
-Oh, well, first of all,
it's just melodies.
They're Mummy melodies.
So there's no --
it's not the lyrics.
It's just like...
[ Vocalizing ]
-So, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
You're telling me --
I've seen the cover art.
It's you with your arm around
a Mummy wearing a Santa hat.
-Yes.
-So I buy that...
there's an expectation I'm going
to hear Mummy holiday songs,
and it's all just melodies?
-But you're going to picture
the mummies
walking around at Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you're
supposed to imagine.
[ Laughter ]
-How many songs are on it?
-22.
[ Laughter ]
-Give it up for Fred Armisen,
everybody!